Wow bro this is me living my best life
hey what's up y'all I'm Kyle SuperDuper
Kyle that is my alter-ego that is the
version of myself that is unstoppable hi
my name is Carl setter and I've been a
comic book artist for 25 years and I'm
here to turn Kyle into a superhero he's
always imagined he could be tell me
about your superhero alter ego Kyle is
kind of like a shy nerdy drama kid and
then super dooper Kyle was this voice in
his head that's like nah dude you're a
superstar
what's his most prominent feature he's
got these big-ass teeth and he goes like
this like big as hell and they just
shine dummy bright like and then like
people are like oh gosh he's got to be
kind of swole can you make me semis well
absolutely
he's definitely swole I would love to go
just fly high up into the clouds and
kind of just get away from everything
and just be able to look down at the
skies you know chill and he's a little
tall you know I mean not too tall but
he's kind of tall attractive yes
Wow oh my god yo dude this is crazy
well one of the things you mentioned
that really resonated with me was you
flying above everything in a positive
way and that's really what I wanted to
capture so there's sort of the great
clouds in the city here and you're sort
of above it yeah and going towards sort
of the positive energy of Tom has made
me think a lot about the you know the
person I'm trying to be you know I mean
even more than what I am today I think I
want to leave this room and try and be
more of this version of myself like
everybody is somebody's superhero and
based on how you act out there in the
world you know I mean depends on who's
gonna say that about you one day this is
eye-opening dude and this is this is
patottie way kind of show it to the
cottage it was like you
[Music]
[Music]